welcome to the man of recaps this is the
expanse seasons one through five leading
up to the sixth and final season it's a
bright future where humanity has
mastered space travel and colonized our
solar system but people are still people
and just can't get along mars has
declared its independence and is in a
tense cold war with earth and spread
across the asteroid belt and beyond are
a whole society of belters they've lived
in space for generations have developed
their own cool creole language and
they're generally oppressed by the
colonial powers earth and mars the
inners our story begins on a nice mining
ship that can't bury with our hero james
holden who used to be earth navy but is
now just kind of chilling when they pick
up a distress call holden takes a small
group to check it out and these become
our main characters there's naomi nagata
genius engineer former belt of freedom
fighter the martian alex kamal ace pilot
and a funny space cowboy type and the
tough guy amos burton who's kind of
friendly but has no problem with
violence but turns out this distress
beacon was a trap a stealth ship comes
out of nowhere and blows up the
canterbury our little crew has to pull
off some dangerous space shenanigans but
they survived and managed to broadcast
what happened and kind of become
celebrities now everyone knows mars is
the only one with stealth tech but
they're rescued by a martian ship like
hey it wasn't us in fact it was a double
trap the stealth ships come back and
blow up the martian ship our canterbury
crews the sole survivors again so down
on earth which is governed by the united
nations we follow christian avasarala
who's pretty high up there she's a tough
politician who's willing to fight dirty
and every other word out of her mouth is
profanity she's generally of the mindset
earth must come first but she's a good
person who doesn't want to rush into war
she tries to figure out what's going on
meanwhile on the asteroid series is
detective miller a jaded old cop with a
cool old school hat he's hard to find
missing heiress julie mao who ran away
from home to fight for belter's rights
as miller investigates she seems like an
incredible person the more he learns the
more he gets a crush on her so our
canterbury crew is contacted by fred
johnson leader of tycho space station
and a big player in the opa the outer
planets alliance is a belter's rights
organization but it's a loose
affiliation of hundreds of factions some
like fred johnson playing by the rules
others fully terrorists one of his ships
was attacked by this mystery stealth
ship too he hires james holden to go
investigate now they escaped the last
battle on a state-of-the-art martian
mini cruiser complete with top-notch
coffee maker they rename it the
rasanante and it's an awesome tough
little ship so they find the missing
ship but something weird happened here
it was infected with a glowing blue
alien fungus holden's not taking any
chances with weird alien stuff they get
out of there and nuke it from orbit the
ship had one survivor though who they
tracked the asteroid arrows where they
ran into some trouble and also detective
miller turns out that survivor is julie
mao but it's too late she was infected
and the man behind the whole conspiracy
the stealth ship and the alien
proto-molecule is her father jewel
pierre mao he discovered it and has been
doing secret illegal experiments in fact
he's got another one planned right now
on eros he's going to infect the entire
colony to see what happens so it's a big
showdown as our crew tries to stop it
but they barely escape with their lives
as for the proto-molecule it's very
unclear what it does but you know
nothing good so in season two our
rasanante crew has become a family a
family with some sexual tension cause
holden and naomi get it on and are in
love with the rest of the series so they
fill in fred johnson on this dangerous
alien parasite and decide they gotta
destroy the whole asteroid but the only
way to do that is by ramming it with the
enormous ship he's building for the
mormons yes there are mormons in space
and they hired fred johnson to build him
in this ark but now he's commandeering
it they also have to plant bombs on
arrows but one of them gets jammed so
miller has to stay behind to hold the
button so the ship's coming at him but
wait what's this it misses but it wasn't
the ship that moved it was the asteroid
somehow the proto-molecule's driving it
and now it's headed straight for earth
miller goes inside to see what's up and
he finds a glowing blue alien julie mao
yeah it's kind of her but she's kind of
in a dream state who knows how the
protomolecule works it's crazy miller
talks are out of destroying the earth
like hey babe why don't we check out
venus instead so they have a blue alien
kiss as they crash the asteroid safely
into venus and the day is saved but the
bad guys are just getting started
they're hoping to weaponize the
proto-molecule get earth and mars to go
to war then sell to both sides profit
the remote moon of jupiter ganymede is
jointly owned by earth and mars one of
the martian marines stationed here is
bobby draper a real badass whose gung-ho
to go to war and now it looks like the
earth forces attack her squad fights
back but wait what is this it's a blue
alien monster but now the cold war's
heating up and the u.n secretary general
doesn't know what to do secretary aaron
wright who's working for mao is pushing
for war but avasaral is there like whoa
hold on peace now bobby draper survived
but her superiors are covering up the
blue alien monster so she does some
investigating and turns out someone in
the martian government is also in on the
conspiracy she gets this evidence to
avasarala who can finally take mao and
aaron right down but now invites her to
a secret meeting where he tries to make
a deal hey this proto-molecule tech is
out there you want to make sure earth
has it but meanwhile aaron wright has
made moves of his own he's framed off
serala to get her fired so mal's like oh
guess we don't need you anymore time to
kill her luckily she brought bobby with
her who brought her martian power armor
goes full master chief on these fools so
these two escape on julie mao's old
racing ship the razorback meanwhile the
rasanate crew has figured out that
protomolecule stuff was going on on
ganymede they befriended botanist whose
daughter was kidnapped turns out they're
injecting kids with the proto-molecule
to turn them into these hybrid monsters
so the rostanante flies to ganymede
where they have to pull off some
dangerous space shenanigans our crew
bust in for a big old fight but wait
where'd the proto-molecule monster go oh
it's stowed away on their ship they try
to shoot this thing but it's immune to
bullets luckily it doesn't seem
interested in killing them it's after
the energy from their drive so they play
fetch with it to get it off the ship and
once it's behind the engine turn it on
oh burned up so in season three
skirmishes are breaking out between
earth and mars and without officer allah
there to plead for peace the scales are
tipped towards war the secretary general
brings in a pacifist priest to even it
out but she fails and the first shots of
an interplanetary war are fired but soon
abu sarah is picked up by the rasanante
she befriends this group of misfits who
are just trying to do the right thing
for the galaxy she's eventually able to
send evidence back to earth so finally
aaron writes going to jail but the
conspiracy goes on without him jewel
pierre mao has yet another secret
research facility so the rasanante heads
for io where earth and mars forces are
also converging it's a complex situation
because both sides have people hoping to
make peace and others pushing for war
and unknown to most of them both planets
face a potential proto-molecule
apocalypse our rostanante crew pulls off
some dangerous space shenanigans and
some proto-molecule blasting in the end
they destroy all the proto-molecule
manage to stop the war save botanist's
daughter and capture jewel pierre mao
huge success avasarala becomes the next
secretary general and earth and mars
make a truce but now on venus the
protomolecule is up to something it rips
this whole ship apart and builds itself
into a giant squid ship it flies out
beyond uranus and turns into a ring gate
so everyone's going to check it out
including the rocinante crew because
james holden's more famous than ever in
fact now they have a reported lady with
them making a documentary on their
adventures the new united opa navy is
coming too they've turned the mormon arc
into their flagship naomi nagata joins
them for now the captain here is her old
friend kamina drummer but she has a
co-captain this old space pirate clay
sashford the opa may be united now but
there's still hundreds of different
factions big ones like fred johnson and
anderson dawes who are only working
together as long as it's convenient
while everyone else is analyzing the
ring this one belter twitch streamer is
like hey i'm gonna be the first one
through unfortunately oh the ring's not
open yet it stops them short but that
wakes it up and now james holden gets a
visit from ghost miller yeah apparently
the proto-molecule absorbed his
consciousness and now it's talking to
holden using miller's personality
because it's someone he knew but first
there's a new problem jule pierre mao's
other daughter clarissa mao who wants
revenge on holden for putting her father
away she's augmented herself with a
bio-enhancement package makes her super
fasted strong she sneaks aboard the u.n
convoy and blows up a ship then releases
a fake video of holden taking credit
everyone's a little trigger-happy and
immediately fire at the rossanate the
only way to escape is into the ring
luckily ghost miller tells them the
secret there's a speed limit it'll let
you in slowly and freeze the fast
torpedo so inside the ring is this big
blue sphere and ghost miller is like hey
kid we gotta go turn this baby on he
got's holding down to the core where he
puts his hand in the thing and wow
trippy vision time basically holden
comes to understand there was an ancient
alien civilization that built these
rings called the builders they were the
blue aliens and they used the
protomolecule as a big part of their
technology but there were some
mysterious orange aliens that wiped them
all out they tried to use this station
as a weapon to burn other systems but it
was too late and they're all extinct now
and now everyone's going into the ring
the martians are still after james
holden and try to blow him up but oh the
ring station does not like that it
starts warming up to assumedly destroy
the entire solar system james holden
talking to protomolecule ghost miller
knows the only way to stop it is to turn
off all their engines and prove they're
not a threat but claise ashford's like
um that sounds crazy i'm just gonna keep
on trying to blow it up so it turns into
a complicated mess with people on all
sides doing what they think is right the
martians are still after the rasanante
crew but in the end bobby draper
switches sides to help her new friends
in the end it's clarissa mao who
realizes holden's actually the good guy
and shuts the engines down and luckily
that works the station disarms and now
opens up all the other ring gates to a
thousand new systems so once again
humanity almost destroyed itself by
infighting but in the end they work
together and the day is saved but now
with access to all of these new
habitable worlds everything has changed
so in season four people have begun
exploring these new ring worlds
avasarala enlists james holden to go
help cause he's the expert now on
dangerous alien stuff and so the
rossanate flies through the ring gates
to the world of illus or newterra and
for the first time our crew is on solid
ground to explore this new alien world
so one problem is a bunch of belters
settled here first but an earth mining
corporation led by this douchebag
mercury is like we have the mining
rights mercury is also pretty sure the
belters blew up his ship so tensions are
high but james holden's like yo i wasn't
said to mediate this i was sent here to
watch out for dangerous alien technology
like this crazy metal beast warm yeah
this planet has some massive alien
structures there's no apparent way in
but with james holden's connection to
proto-molecule miller the door opens up
for him miller tells him how to turn it
on but maybe that wasn't the best idea
holden's now taking a zero tolerance
approach to any alien stuff pretty soon
of course the humans start fighting each
other but one of the alien structures
melts down a huge tsunami's coming and
it also shut down their ship engines
there's no evacuating their only option
is to take cover inside the alien
structure and ride it out together and
things are not good in here everyone but
holden catches an eye fungus that turns
him blind and the water washed in these
alien slugs that are covered in a deadly
nerve toxin but now something weird
happens with miller apparently he breaks
free of the protomolecule control and
it's just actually miller's
consciousness so he leads holding down
to the core and hopes to shut this whole
thing down they find this mysterious
orange circle thing and miller's like
hey i'm gonna put myself in a robot body
and walk on through but meanwhile
mercury's up to no good he tries to
attack the rossanante and there's more
dangerous space shenanigans amos burton
had hilarious romance this season with
mercury's right-hand woman he generally
seems like he'll shoot anyone without
even feeling bad about it but the
question is if she chooses her boss will
amos shoot her and the answer is yes
though he does feel a little bad about
it so james holden's gotta go for a wild
west duel with mercury where he wins and
ghost miller got into a robot body the
scientist they had with him gets him
through the thing the whole planet shuts
down spaceships have power again and the
day is saved but elsewhere there's been
other problems inside the ring the
belters have re-renamed the mormon ship
to medina station this is an important
foothold and could theoretically become
the heart of a new true belter nation
but while most belters are working
together for a peaceful future some
still want to destroy the inner planets
like marco and naros in fact he attacks
earth so after allah has to retaliate
but the mission's a huge failure and
this is especially bad because it's an
election year avasaral is being
challenged by a younger hipper version
of her nancy gao officer olaf fights
real dirty but in the end she still
loses the election meanwhile on mars
bobby draper has been dishonorably
discharged for disobeying orders and
siding with the rosannate crew and in
fact everything on mars is now falling
apart a huge part of martian society was
the dream of mars to terraform it into a
lush garden planet but that's still
gonna take another hundred years and
with the ring gates giving access to all
these new already habitable worlds it's
kinda pointless furthermore with the
ever looming threat of war with earth
the military was a huge part of their
society but now that they've made a
lasting peace treaty they're disarming
so everyone's unemployed bobby gets
wrapped up with a gang stealing and
selling some decommissioned military
equipment but eventually her little crew
is set up there's someone higher in
active military selling their real
dangerous stealth tack it turns out they
sold it to belter terrorist marco inaros
now kamina drummer and claise ashford
were opposed last season but they've
become good friends now ashford leaves
to capture marco anaros and it's an
awesome scene the old space pirates
still got it he almost gets him but
marco's got backup his son phillip who
incidentally is naomi nagata's son yeah
she and marco were together back in the
day when she was a freedom fighter so he
space's old ashford who goes out singing
the sea shanty while marco anaros
creates a stealth asteroid and launches
it right at earth so in season five the
rostanante crew takes some vacation time
after their alien planet adventure james
holden's back on taiko station where
reporter girls like hey i heard fred
johnson still has his proto-molecule
sample hey man you gotta destroy it it's
too dangerous there's an ancient war
between orange and blue aliens we don't
want to get involved amos goes back to
earth to his hometown of baltimore it's
been hinted at but he had a real rough
childhood growing up on the mean streets
he comes back now cause his adopted
mother just died and while he's here he
pays a visit to his old best friend
who's now the crime lord of baltimore
turns out amos burton was the previous
crime lord who they overthrew amos's
real name is timmy and while he's here
he visits a supermax prison for people
with bio enhancements to see clarissa
mao they kind of became friends as
people who've done bad stuff in their
past but are trying to be better alex
kamal also goes home to mars we've
always heard that he had a family there
but they've been estranged don't really
want anything to do with him but he does
meet up with bobby draper who's now
officially working undercover for
avasarala to figure out who in the
martian military selling these weapons
they take julie mao's old racing ship to
try to spy on an arms deal when naomi
nigata gets word her son phillip is out
there she's got to go see him and make
sure he doesn't follow in his terraced
father's footsteps so she has a
homecoming 2 with her old opa buddies
but it's too late for philip he's mad at
her for abandoning him in fact he takes
her hostage brings her to her old flame
marco inaros and in space the stealth
asteroid is still on its way to earth in
fact he launched a couple avasarala's
been demoted she's got a small
government position on the moon luna
with no real power but she figures out
marco's plan no one's listening to her
though and it's too late the first
asteroid hits earth now they listen to
her but it's too late another meteor
hits right by air force one wiping out
the earth government in the end three
asteroids got through which has caused
immense damage marco narrows declares
himself the leader of the new opa free
navy and he doesn't want to just be
equal with earth he wants to dominate it
in fact he led simultaneous attacks
across the system taking out other
leaders like fred johnson and now he's
uniting all belter factions under his
flag including one of our main
characters kamina drummer after last
season drummer was fed up with the
politics and went back to her roots as a
space pirate a good space pirate who
doesn't kill civilians and is just
having fun with her crew of best friends
polygamous lovers she hates marco cause
he's awful and killed a friend ashford
but she doesn't really have a choice
it's a join or die situation now marco
also sent a spider robot to steal fred
johnson's proto-molecule sample so james
holden's got to get it back but naomi
manages to get a message to him they
planted a bomb on the rostanante that
was a close one now philip's been
talking to his mom who's trying to pull
him back to the light side but he's got
his dad on his other shoulder like stay
with me on the dark side in the end he
picks his dad so they're finally going
to execute naomi but she managed to nab
an oxygen thing and it's dangerous space
shenanigans she does the epic space jump
makes it to her ship unfortunately they
rigged the ship to explode with a
distress call to lord james holden here
and even genius engineer naomi nagata
can't undo it though she tries really
hard so holden goes after the
proto-molecule he brings reporter girl
with him as well as fred johnson's new
head of security bull he gets naomi's
fake distress call but if he leaves
he'll lose the trail luckily alex and
bobby are actually nearby they have
their own adventure at the arms deal so
the rasanate catches up to the ship and
destroys it finally the protomolecule is
all the way gone but marco had ordered
drummer squad to intercept so the
rostanante now finds itself surrounded
but now drummer makes her move takes
command of her ship back and switches
sides to save the rostanante what's up
holden i got your back but now alex and
bobby come in to rescue naomi and she
can't warn them it's a trap so she does
the only thing she can and jumps out of
the spaceship luckily they see her but
the hygiene maneuvers required to save
her are incredibly dangerous by the way
when they do high g stuff they like
inject this milk into their veins and if
you do too much it could kill you but
alex kamal's like hey i've survived tons
of dangerous space shenanigans i gotta
try and so they managed to save naomi
but this time alex does not survive he
dies it's tragic he was one of the best
funniest characters and one of the core
four rostanate crew unfortunately the
actor was apparently a sexual predator
but the rest of our rossanante crew are
reunited including amos burton who made
it off earth luckily when the asteroid
hit they were deep underground and he
had a whole big adventure with clarissa
mao and his old best friend in fact now
aimus forces holden to let clarissa mao
join the crew it's like i know she tried
to kill you two seasons ago but she's a
good guy now back on earth with most of
the government wiped out this random guy
takes over as secretary general per
usual he's got the warhawks like we need
to retaliate but officer allah like if
we hit civilians we'll just turn them
against us in the end he sides with the
war guys so wavasarala resigns but a
bunch of the cabinet agrees with her and
they nominate her the new secretary
general again and so everyone meets up
on luna and it's like hey if all of us
work together we can have a peaceful
future but marco anaros is just getting
started he leads his free navy to the
ringgate and takes it over and he had
help from a rogue group of the martian
military turns out he made a secret deal
to help them get into the ring gate
because they are leaving this system
behind this rogue martian faction has
started settling a new planet with a
bunch of the dangerous alien technology
and turns out the proto-molecule wasn't
actually destroyed they got it off in
time and marco gave it to these martians
so who knows what they'll be able to do
with the ancient builder technology
maybe destroy the entire galaxy but as
these bad martians pass through the ring
gate to their new system laconia on this
one ship something unexpected happens
it's the orange aliens who destroy this
ship who knows what they are or how they
work but it seems like they're waking up
and may be a bigger threat than anything
else going on find out how this epic
space adventure comes to an end on the
final season of the expanse
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you love
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member